[Music]
here we go
uh xqc has white
he is is he aware the game star yes he
is he is where the game stands
okay and you never know because he's
literally solving puzzles he's doing all
kinds of stuff all the time so here we
go
the french is on yes
right so so far pretty pretty standard i
mean i like the way that pokemon is
playing this i think her position
it's very stable it's not there aren't
really many opportunities to blunder at
least in the next couple of moves so
it's
it i think it's a great start for it's
about as good of a start as she could
have asked for
yeah okay queen e4 is a threat now from
from x which would be
super solid i like queen d7 though very
nice moves you
you saw queen eight was a threat
retreats to clean backward
yep very nice this what this is uh
this is gonna do a lot to improve both
their cap scores i'll tell you that
they're playing really accurate chess
here
that that's actually a very good point
you're right because for pokeman she has
made no blunder so
you're right the accuracy is going to be
very high both players are probably
going to be like 90
is my guess yeah and it's funny because
sometimes it's the style of the game
that can lead to a higher cap score
everyone i mean okay
it's always if you don't make blunders
if you oh
oh oh my oh my gosh he tried to cheese
her he didn't realize it's check
he didn't realize his check he tried to
cheese her
oh i think he thought he had a
background checkmate if she takes but if
she takes it's just checked
and i think she'll see it too because
it's just like right there in front of
her
uh we go minus one 100 here 100
i didn't see it through i think yeah he
thought he had a background checkmate
yeah he said he didn't think it through
it's okay though okay
it's done it's fine it's fine i i want
to get that guy out of there it's so
annoying i need we need that piece out
asap oh i could have just threatened to
take queen
oh that was the right move there dude
and she goes right back your car looks
very nice
very nice by pokeman she spotted the
idea of um
of the back rank here and she just takes
the juicer and goes back
let's do it i mean she could also just
take
right and then free her back rank but
but this would be a super strong find
and x might miss checkmate yeah i
totally could see him missing it he
could really tunnel on the checkmate
pattern of the back rank like queen d5
knight g4
or knight c4 to go queen e8 right oh
that's a great point yeah because if she
goes here he'll be thinking about moving
his knight for his
checkmate and you could easily miss
your opponent okay she goes queen h3
which is also quite good and now after
king g1 will she play rookie eight
that's the that's the one piece that's
not in the game here
will she play rookie eight if she does x
x is in big trouble like
big trouble super scary to play though
because we know she's got to be nervous
about the back rank as you talked about
it before
right yeah okay she does take which is
which is also fine but now after queen
takes
of course it's literally your back rank
or go home you can't yeah you have to be
very careful here
now she could also just start checking
as well i could see her checking
right
like if she checks the game probably
will be a draw i'm guessing
he plays h6 which is okay very nice
although now
x is back in the game if he starts pawn
goblin like you said
hicaro she might might just settle on
the draw and
and just say well you know what that's
how it is yeah and just keep checking
right
it could happen i i don't i i mean i
don't know but i think if
i'm x you have to be looking to take the
pawn on c5 here but it can be scary
because your king is so open as well
gotta go you gotta go just play g6 here
oh no oh no
i forgot i can't oh my god
okay oopsie
oh she was oh man it was just a tough
spot
yeah brutal
oh so unfortunate yeah you really
shouldn't be frustrated about this game
though this was such a great game
yeah yeah i i mean it's it's unfortunate
but
again i think that the takeaway from
this game is that she played really well
i mean she was in the game up until
up until that blunder with the queen
when she thought for three minutes and
blunder
she just resigns the game yeah um we'll
just show it again for those it may be
happening too fast the main point again
is that the pawn is pinned yeah right
exactly well pokey is
excuse me back at it with her london
system it worked very well against
rubius earlier and
uh xqc has has also put the knight on c6
which is the same development that ruby
has chosen so
um now he's taking his time
yeah so far again pretty standard i like
what uh what pokey is doing just bring
the knight out to f3 of course
and i'm just keep it rolling well there
she goes and
x is on the clock again but remember if
you missed game one he was down
he was down a full three minutes if not
more in game one and ultimately he was
able to catch up so
um i i kind of i think you're right he
obviously needs to work on his openings
i also like that he's willing to figure
it out when he feels like he might be
losing his way
right i agree now this is a very
dangerous spot for him i think he almost
has to take on e5 with the bishop here
there are very few moves that i think
are um oh
no oh no what is that
oh no that's terrible
oh no just realizes it now that is
terrible
[Laughter]
take take
oh that is not cool i could sacrifice a
piece here then
take take
good idea by him the g5 idea take
yeah g5 is actually a very yeah um
i mean it doesn't work but i really as
creative thinking by him
yeah yeah i think it's very creative to
play cheat
i think he should play it actually
because there's a chance that pokeman
will not remember to retreat the bishop
why not i have to chat
i i i bugged it good move very nice
it is what it is no he's super
resourceful
like in general i don't want to see if
she wins i don't i don't want to
discredit her win
okay so i'm gonna ignore it okay but it
for the participant record it was a
genuine misclick
okay so actually actually saying that he
made a genuine
take for that with knight takes that bad
though
wow because he has a fork that's why it
was a bad move
that's why i didn't want to go for that
yeah this this actually opens up my rook
surprisingly
the problem with this current game is
that this pawn is blocking is blocking
this formation of my pawns which blocks
this glass
about what is strong very nice
let's come back to the board and show
the potential misclick there it is one
of the risks sometimes we know that x
kind of clicks on the pieces to see the
squares they move and maybe
maybe he was considering taking and
accidentally clicked on the night
and that's what happened so that's
that's unfortunate but
but also again very resourceful by him
he was trying to distract the bishop
so that he could take here which would
have been a genius idea
but pokey says nope i'm just going to
safely back up
mm-hmm yeah this is a big fork here oh
oh whoa she can just take the knight now
i guess we'll see which one she takes
either capture is really really good
yep
i but i would take the knight here okay
she takes the bishop completely fine
though completely fine
um i really i i like her position i
think she's she's doing very well
yeah and obviously she can take with the
age pawn and i agree with you totally
obviously queen takes knight probably a
little more accurate but if she takes
with the h pawn
she's still in really good shape and she
does
he's very quiet suddenly
and then yes yes
pawn up bishop up
bishop takes rook takes skewer queen
takes
juicer oh my goodness i see so many
moves
i see the moves what about wait a minute
what if i pawn up and quintix
who cares i'll talk about that later
she's plus three but i'm not scared i i
have this
[Music]
i have that
i i yeah it's an investment okay i play
like normally
eight to ten moves ahead i see in the
future oh
oh don't trade man that's dude that's
kind of weird bro
oh come on that's not cool man
yeah no i mean i don't think he's gonna
trade
i have to go for it wow he does
surprising whatever dude
he sees e5 though with the idea of
bishop f5 which is really really really
warm
i can still do it i can still do it
i like it yup oh yeah
bad position bad position but they're
all bad positions all of them
it still works will i see it it does
yeah
okay so she's gonna i hope she doesn't
tunnel and take
get that one so you can think of what
oh this is fantastic oh this is life
this is life
this is this is something else i i win
this
minus two but this is i don't see her
getting out of this
the bunch of blight is going in
[Laughter]
take take gigi okay what else
what else whatever she does
i yeah it's over
oh what a strong idea it is
yeah very very impressive that he found
this
and then we go even okay it's not so bad
she's only down one pawn so it's not
it's not actually the end of the world
here yeah
and also after pawn takes pawn you can
take with the knight yeah
if e3 e3 just move your knight you're
still winning back a lot of your
right
this is gonna come down to the wire here
right so bishop takes bishop so she
takes the pawn
oh wait a minute
what about that i missed that
that releases i know he sees it oh wow
he sees it
and she allows wow
oh wow brutal
totally brutal and he is
taking him through his stomach that's
art that is that is legitimate
yeah it's over here comes my
absolute one million head late game my
my legitimate advanced brain
late game
i mean pogie is still in it though if
she can move quickly that's annoying if
she can keep the time closer i still
think it's anyone's game because again
the knight is easier to move than a
bishop but she's got to move quicker
um and try to get back get back ahead on
the clock
i could get checkmated right here fast
think check check king moves
check okay
king moves
upwards check
all defended palm moves oh my gosh
we've got to move just go king king
three just move
i think you're the king we've been
liking it
come on you gotta go you gotta make a
move come on pokey move move the king
if i don't play this right i'm checkmate
well that's not gonna happen
okay king of three e3 nice i got it
everything
everything i said i was gonna do i did
it
you gotta move what is she doing seven
just to move e1
king d1 yes keep going
oh he found c6 wow no no no no not trim
anymore i can't move now
wow there it is
wow so close
wow crazy
all right that's is that better
yes yes six zero
undefeated yes baby
did it boys
he he should be celebrating because he
has worked his ass off and we see him
grinding with puzzles and playing hard
and i gotta i gotta be honest
carl as a guy that we know he had some
tough moments in pog one let's be honest
one of the most viral tough moments
of all time right and look at what he's
done hey carl his community has
supported him
he has overcome what was a crazy moment
from pogba one and i don't care what
anyone says pokey has a bright future
but that was incredible chess by xqc
and he deserves it it's mixed feelings
uh because of a lot of things
i feel like uh since i'm more of an
intuitive player that didn't really uh
uh reach back for like a coaching or
whatever
it feels good to uh put a little bit of
time in
but but see my strategies and what i
thought about
pay off in the grand scheme of things
does that make sense it does
so uh it it feels good i think i i could
have been a little bit cleaner but it
was really good games
all around today i think all game's
really exciting it wasn't like one-sided
or
it wasn't like high accuracy normal
standard robotic play it was i think it
was pretty fun today
i do feel like i put up a pretty good
fight for my first pogchamp so i'm
really i'm really happy i just didn't
want it to be like a
you know like the snowball or super
super one-sided so as long as it was
kind of dynamic fun to watch i'm happy
your pog champs isn't over yet x can
tell you the consolation bracket is
where the party is right
yes yeah yeah yeah it's it's like it's
like the brawl it's the gauntlet
and um i think those brackets are spicy
yeah it's always always really exciting
uh to go to the little record i think
well ex
speaking of being up on the clock you
seem to be making more of a concerted
effort as the game goes on
you tend to your pattern is you tend to
get behind on the clock in the opening
you kind of know that right you get
behind and then you sped up though in
these games and ultimately you weren't
down on the clock in either of the final
critical moments what what are you doing
to work on your
on your time management in your own
chess uh
i think a little bit like uh like a tree
right so sometimes
uh when it's when we're about mid game
where you kind of have to make your core
strategy
i think of the trunk like the big chunk
of the strategy right
okay these these pieces can move over
there and i i try to get a uh
a mental map of what can happen right
and
i feel like once i build that core as
uh i start actually playing and i'm
alone on the clock
it's easier to get to the branches does
that make sense it's easier to branch
out and get away from the core and
and start trickling out of it i i do
think chess games
if you know your end games tend to be
kind of like a bell curve
where the most complicated parts are in
the middle um and the parts that require
the most thinking so
in that sense very well played xpc
[Music]
you